from special effects inspired by 80s
comedies the near casting of a Harry
Potter star there's much more to
everything everywhere all at once the
meets the eye
according to vulture the Genesis of
everything everywhere all that once can
be traced back to the most unlikely of
movies Sherman's March the 1985
documentary introduced directors Daniel
scheinert and Daniel Quan known
collectively as the Daniels to the
concept of modal realism from there they
began to do some digging and started
learning more about professional
theories regarding the Multiverse a
common theme in everything from art to
mathematics the concept was immediately
intriguing to the filmmaking Duo since
it appealed to their maximalist
Tendencies as artists the pair are
always looking to cram as much stuff as
possible into their directorial efforts
whether that be a music video or a movie
so being able to explore many different
dimensions was extremely engaging to
their creative sensibilities despite how
ridiculous The Works of the Daniels
seemingly are these two directors were
also extremely interested in the science
behind these Concepts and did their
research accordingly this gave some
tangible grounding for all the madness
that would eventually be Unleashed in
their exploration of the Multiverse and
everything everywhere all at once
it's impossible to imagine a version of
everything everywhere all at once that
isn't anchored by Michelle yo she's the
heart and soul of the entire picture
while scenes in the movie even use
actual archival footage of yo at events
like the premiere of crazy Rich Asians
everything everywhere all at once and yo
are deeply intertwined so it's somewhat
insane to realize that she wasn't the
first choice for the character of Evelyn
originally this figure was going to be a
man and would have been portrayed by
another legend of the Silver Screen
Jackie Chan
going to be painful you're right about
that co-director Daniel scheinert
admitted to The Hollywood Reporter that
he and Daniel Quan originally thought
that everything everywhere or that once
needed a male lead says it was an action
movie with a pair eyeballing Jackie Chan
to fill that role yo was always meant to
be in the film but she was originally
assigned the part of the protagonist's
wife however as they continued working
on the film the director's got the idea
that the story would be much better if
Yo's character was a protagonist
suddenly a whole new world of narrative
possibilities opened up while this meant
abandoning the idea of casting Chan it's
impossible to complain about his absence
considering how excellent yo is as
Evelyn
in August 2018 The Hollywood Reporter
revealed that Michelle yo and Aquafina
were in talks to headline everything
everywhere all at once it was a casting
choice that would reunite the two
performers after they worked together on
crazy Rich Asians who was hot coming
after Art House hit the farewell however
by January 2020 as everything everywhere
all at once was to begin filming
Aquafina was no longer part of its cast
the official reason for this development
was never revealed but it was presumably
due to scheduling complex while losing
Aquafina may have been a bummer it
didn't slow down everything everywhere
all at once which plowed ahead with
principal photography and scored other
lead performers like Stephanie shu
Michelle Yo's legendary career has
spanned countless genres and iconic
films yet even she had never appeared in
a movie quite like everything everywhere
all at once before tasked with playing
protagonist Evelyn yo got to build on
her gifts for Comic timing and fight
choreography but also got to play in a
much more absurdist world than she'd
ever previously participated in some
actors my book have been asked to join
such an unusual feature but yo was
enthusiastic from the start mainly
because of the prospect of getting work
with directors Daniel Quan and Daniel
sheinert they thought you know she can
do this Joe was also enthusiastic about
getting to play a character like Evelyn
who inhabited an archetype that she felt
was often erased entirely in cinematic
narratives not only getting to inhabit
that role but getting to play her as an
empowered protagonist filled yo with
excitement on top of all that yo was
further enticed to join everything
everywhere all at once because of how
much dedication everyone involved had to
the movie such passion is infectious and
proved to be a key ingredient among many
to securing Yo's participation in this
unforgettably unorthodox movie
having Evelyn work in a laundromat is a
great choice on so many levels for
everything everywhere all at once for
one thing it puts his character and her
family in the midst of working class
life just seeing her walk around in her
workplace makes it clear what kind of
financial difficulty she navigates daily
it also creates an instantaneous
Underdog sensibility in Evelyn that
contrasts nicely with her eventual
transformation into a warrior who can
plug abilities from differing Dimensions
but there's also a deeply personal
reason for making this Evelyn's
occupation director Daniel Quan revealed
to Digital Spy that his grandfather ran
a laundromat when he came to New York
City from Hong Kong remembering his
dad's stories about growing up directly
above a laundromat Juan new occupation
ever then had to work in Quan also noted
that the laundromat turned out to be a
perfect extension for the film's central
message of finding the beauty and
seemingly throwaway parts of everyday
life
the cast of everything everywhere all at
once is perfect proof of how a movie is
defined by every member of its Ensemble
and not just his leads Michelle yo and
kiwei Quan are indispensable in their
performances as the story's protagonist
but this movie wouldn't be complete
without the terrific supporting turns
from Jamie Lee Curtis and Stephanie Shu
among many others all these impressively
committed performances swell together to
cement the creatively bold aesthetic of
the entire movie and nobody was more
aware of how important all these actors
were than Michelle yo yo noted to the AV
club that her character would not be
able to function in the narrative
without the film supporting characters
and performances such richly detailed
and human turns were especially critical
in the eyes of yo because everything
everywhere all at once is such a
heightened sci-fi story trying to convey
a deeply grounded message about the
importance of kindness balancing those
contrasting Concepts could have gone
badly wrong under other circumstances
but yo was grateful to be surrounded by
a superb ensemble cast and executed the
movie's complex tone and message with
finesse
before they directed everything
everywhere all at once filmmaking Duo
Daniels made their feature lender's
directorial debut with the 2016 indie
film Swiss army man it was just a kind
of project that immediately cemented the
Paris directors to watch thanks to its
complicated tone and bold imagery plus
it contained a gopher broad performance
from Daniel Radcliffe as a corpse that
can talk fart and anything else you can
imagine radicle if was an essential part
of why Swiss army man didn't collapse
under the weight of his own strangeness
so it's no surprise that the Daniels
wanted to reunite with the actor on
everything everywhere all at once
Radcliffe revealed on the a24 podcast
that he would have appeared as a hot dog
dancer in a fictional movie that plays
in Evelyn's laundromat Radcliffe was
incredibly excited about the idea of
being in the film with such a wacky role
however the actor couldn't do the part
solely because of scheduling conflicts
with his stage performances in a series
of plays in London in the world of New
York theater Stephanie she was already
built of a remarkable career prominent
roles and musicals like be more chill
and the SpongeBob musical have helped
solidify her as a performer to watch out
for in the domain of movies though Chu's
experience is a bit more limited though
she landed a massive breakthrough on the
big screen thanks to her work and
everything everywhere all at once
talking with collider about her
experience shooting the movie she said
that this being her first major Motion
Picture role inspired her to just go for
broken her on-screen performance being
unfamiliar with how film sets operate
she threw caution to the wind and
embrace all the possibilities of her
idiosyncratic character she noted that
it was easy to get into that mindset
because of how committed everyone else
was on the set of the film Shu couldn't
have asked for a better or more unique
launch pad to begin her feature film
acting career I love movies I want to
make movies forever and ever it is the
best
in 2002 kiwei Quan stepped away from
acting due to a lack of opportunities
for Asian actors the truth is as I got
older there was just not a lot of
opportunities for an Asian actor at that
time after years of working in behind
the scenes roles on various projects his
performance and everything everywhere
all at once was his first acting Credit
in roughly two decades Quan noted that
his lengthy absence from acting meant he
was extremely nervous before the cameras
started to roll however Quan recalled at
the moment the camera started rolling he
was brought back to his days of acting
as a kid and felt immediately
comfortable again making his time on the
everything everywhere or the one set
even more pleasant was Quan's excitement
over getting to work with Michelle yo
and everyone else on the cast plus Crown
was enormously grateful for the script
that the Daniels wrote the kind of
screenplay and carotid always wanted to
work with but had never gotten the
chance to embrace until now
everything everywhere well at once is an
incredibly High concept Motion Picture
involving raccoons tugging on people's
hair enormous pessimistic bagels and
everything in between it's no surprise
that it required lots of visual effects
Wizardry to bring it to life what is
surprising though is both how these
visual effects were created and how many
resources were dedicated to those
effects in a breakdown by Indie wire it
was revealed that 80 of the visual
effects shots and everything everywhere
all at once were handled by just five
people although this Indie feature
didn't have armies of technicians and
artists at its disposal everything
everywhere all at once did have a
dedicated team of visual effects Wizards
who found inspiration in some all-time
great movies specifically the group
looked towards 1980s Classics like
Ghostbusters or Who Framed Roger Rabbit
for inspiration on how to make tangible
images without relying solely on CGI
this dedicated gaggle of artists also
turned to programs like after effects to
realize many of the most complicated
visual effects details in the film they
didn't have Cutting Edge technology on
their side but the film's visual effects
team delivered state-of-the-art work
with endearingly ramshackle means
defying the odds everything everywhere
all the once made his bugs of his
prowess apparent early on when it
managed to increase two percent in its
second weekend of wide release movies
almost always decreased in ticket sales
week to week but the word of mouth kept
this one around in the public
conversation everything everywhere all
the ones held on astonishingly well week
to week and despite opening and limited
release on the last weekend of March
2022 was still playing in wide release
by the 4th of July the film eventually
cracked 70 million dollars domestically
nearly three times as 25 million dollar
budget everything everywhere all at once
also proved to be a lucrative Enterprise
in foreign markets where we managed to
make another 30 million dollars with
this Hall everything everywhere all at
once cracked 100 million dollars
globally nobody could have ever imagined
this movie doing this well but then
again it's fitting that a movie as
unusual as everything everywhere all at
once would have a box office run that
breaks all the rules
[Music]
foreign